berne le tibet compte 1 2 3 bat express
est parti on commence sur ces news on a
découvert le booba des chroniqueurs chez
pascal praud vous allez voir il est
toujours vénère n'avait pas à chaque
fois à ricaner dès que je dis que je
n'aime pas la messe mais est-ce que je
peux terminer des phrases bon sang de
bois et a cessé avec cette usine
chimique manoir 10,3 me pardonnait pas
non camille 11 ap sur tf1 et on n'a pas
trop compris ce caissier de nous dire
les eaux mattei alias jean-luc reichmann
le tiche en 1991 ce soit quasiment neuf
mois après la fugue des relents g et de
nadine nadine et alice ne sont pas seuls
elles sont mères et filles et donc
thierry et à langer et son père
sur france 3 y avait slam l'émission où
tous les candidats sont profs on sait
pas pourquoi le professeur des écoles
qu'est ce que vous faites dans la vie
disait alors je suis professeur des
écoles question fait dans la vie en deux
matches et on a eu droit à un moment
bien gênant stresser un peu non un petit
peu savaient comment on fait quand on
est stressé on crie très fort
1 2 3 on est pas dans la merde
a part ça le rugby c'est un ballon du
courage mais aussi beaucoup de tendresse
blatter
[Musique]
pour les marseillais
maeva adore la géographie en revanche la
géographie qui veut pas trop mais va
lorsqu'on est sur leurs ânes parce que
je crois que sur le rhône à paris le
même péniche et sophie davant un peu de
mal avec le nom de ses candidates
bonjour mais habile un bon jour qu'on
vous voit bien parti - pardon et voilà
babin exprès c'est fini et si jean luc
hees est pas possible ou là on se calme
allez pour bisous et à demain
voilà deux qui s'est passé revenir sur
un extrait oui gilles sur le 4 c'est
quoi alors le rugby c'est le joueur
anglais qui avait cédé coconnier du
gallois c'est extraordinaire parce qu'en
plus il a un regard mais il a l'air de
se moquer de lui alors je dis c'est
extraordinaire il risque une énorme
sanctions dans ses rangs un oui de 12
semaines à plusieurs années de
suspension très précis mais il avait
cité et je crois qu'ils les a pris pour
un buzzer directeur va revoir regarder
on va voir avec l'angleterre
[Musique]
c'est le capitaine gallois il l'a très
mal pris
il va citer ça va c'est jour de sentir
les quatre ça y est on est déjà venu du
sud vous comprenez le principe et merci
oui il ronge à une blague à easy cd mais
qui sont à présent il y en a un qui dit
à l'autre tu as pris combien toit et
j'ai pris chez moi mais tu as fait quoi
et d'imagés volées des bagnoles le
sinistre et toi tu après combien et moi
j'ai pris fin qu'en cinq ans mais t'as
fait quoi
j'ai violé un poussin avons à violer un
poussin mais ça vaut pas cinq ans d'ici
c'est un un poussin de l'équipe de rugby
de à leiria que gilles qui travaille
alors sur la base ebooks oui c'est ivan
rioufol donc c'est un chroniqueur qui
est toujours 400 lapins est jeune et il
est vaincu les astros
mais pourquoi qu'on soit d'accord ou pas
avec lui j'aime bien parce qu'il défend
à fond il est toujours vénérée au jour à
chaque fois rien et dès que je dis que
les jaunes et canpages mais est-ce que
je peux terminer des phrases donc sans
de boire et à cesser avec sept succès de
ce geek manoir ne parvenaient pas non
voilà alors il y avait d'autres virages
aussi samedi sur tf1 grand reportage
s'est intéressé aux arnaques et plus
exactement aux escroqueries sur la toile
vous allez voir qu'il y en a beaucoup et
que ça peut parfois aller très très loin
on a d'abord vu l'histoire de christine
cristina s'étaient inscrits sur un
réseau social pour trouver l'amour est
un homme va la contacter racing va se
laisser séduire
et ça va lui coûter très très cher à
christine regarder tout a commencé par
un simple message de cet homme sur un
réseau social
il dit s'appeler dominique perrin
christine traverse une période difficile
elle est en plein divorce et ses
messages la réconforte may cry cry je
pense tout le temps à toi après quelques
mois d'idylle virtuel dominique lui
annonce qu'il a perdu son emploi et
qu'il n'a plus de quoi nourrir sa fille
il demande à christine de l'aider
j'aurais voulu avoir une carte pcs à
valros ce ticket permet d'effectuer des
transactions à l'étranger en toute
discrétion le destinataire peut retirer
l'argent anonymement en un an et demi
christine envoie plus de 10000 euros à
dominique dans l'espoir qu'ils viennent
la rejoindre à grenoble la cause
possible
l'apport que tu joues et jean-michel moi
il n'y a pas un jour presque qui ce
passe temps je reçois des messages comme
ça mais ce message personnalisé
cherchons mon instinct ou sur mon
facebook site a deux filles font
seulement de me draguer et au bout
rapidement au bout de quelques questions
je me rends compte que c'est un mec qui
drague qui me demande de lui envoyer de
l'argent mais tous les jours passés à
gourin alors qu'ils seront east il se
ils se trompent avec des fautes
d'orthographe basique ou lave ou
d'hormones les mêmes questions le
lendemain ils ont déjà posé la veille
il parla tellement de gens même temps
qu'ils confondent leurs vers rémy alors
et le magazine a poussé une enquête ils
ont découvert que l'argent christine
avait atterri en côte d'ivoire et là bas
ils ont rencontré ce qu'on appelle un
bouteur fabriquer pas les images chevaux
alors ils ont abreuvé un bouteur ce sont
ceux qui font ces arnaques au regard des
citoyens des bouteurs abidjan en côte
d'ivoire est le royaume des escrocs du
coeur c'est ici que christina envoyer
toutes ses économies à c'est lui qui
disait limite les faubourgs celle-ci
souvent l'acide et le pommeau raffy
florence et en deux ans célibataire et
giflé mist et j'habite à lyon eu le cul
amadio m mais si tu es vraiment très
chamois et ça commence ici du compte sa
sympathie à le diamant voulu avec les
photos qui n'en valent la peine après la
mise en confiance on dérange une course
d'une agent maintenant voilà et c'est
vrai que la pauvre christine a perdu
beaucoup beaucoup de sous et c'est pas
la seule alors mais aussi d'autres
arnaques
on a par exemple vu jordan qui lui avait
acheté une très belle voiture sauf
qu'ils ne peut pas vraiment la conduire
regarder pourquoi on s'est donné rendez
vous le matin à 10 heures
la voiture était conforme à l'annonce
165 mille kilomètres 4300 euros
ça me semblait une bonne affaire mais il
va très vite déchanté
jordan n'a jamais réussi à établir une
carte grise à son nom
ils suivent aliments certifiés qu' il
n'avait pas ce temps tête en fait c'est
que du faux falsification
le contrôle technique qui est totalement
faux de la société n'existe pas cette
voiture je les ai achetés à 165 mille
kilomètres est réellement là on a trois
cent douze mille way ce qui est fou dans
ce cas c'est que parfois on se dit bon
bah ils ont pas vérifié ils n'ont pas
bien voilà on les a arnaqué mais
franchement ils auraient pu voir là en
l'occurrence dans le cas de ce garçon
c'est que vraiment il avait tout il
avait il avait vraiment des documents
que sur blaye être réelle vie est très
bien fait et voilà et donc que ça veut
dire que nous y compris là qu'il ya un
truc qui fait freinage souvent c'est pas
simple acheté la semaine est acheté
pendant les heures ouvrables que soient
les chèques de banque vous appelez la
banque le technique
on va l'appeler ensemble contrôle
technique facture du garage on va les
avoir mais les mecs le disent après les
mecs te dise non mais tu inquiets de la
voiture aller plus avant d'aller vendus
il raccroche il était passé à côté d'une
emmerdes
alors là il ya lieu de la voir pauline
voulais juste partir en vacances elle
avait tout trouver la destination de la
maison sauf qu'une fois arrivé là bas ça
c'est pas du tout passé comme elle le
souhaitait regarder cette cadre
parisienne avait répondu à une annonce
publiée sur le site abritel pour une
très belle villa à 2500 euros
mais une fois sur place c'est la douche
froide
mon arrivée on en trouvait le
propriétaire à l'intérieur de la maison
qu'on avait loué pour la semaine
propriétaires qui nous a assuré ne
jamais avoir mis la maison en location
sur le site par lequel on était passé et
donc très clairement on a compris
courbatures alors c'est vrai sauf que
oui on voit le patron d'abritel qui dit
que justement là c'est la faute des gens
parce qu'en fait les gens après ils vont
ils vont sur des sites parallèles vivons
sur les mails des gens donc en fait il
parce qu par le site abritel et passe
par le mail directement de la maison
donc c'est défaut d'accord très bien
faire attention merci à l'été des
anecdotes fusent et les glottes mois
sans aucun il ya quelques années elle ma
grand mère l'aiment département à cannes
oui et on allait comme ça l'était par an
à cannes
je comprenais la concierge même ribeiro
pouf on arrive on arrive très bien
s'appelle manon ribeiro mais un jour
d'après on a prévient pas et on décide
d'y aller un week end juste comme ça
c'est moi qui conduis on arrive
en fait cet appartement on rentrait
c'était les bronzés vous avez une
famille à 4 est en train de dîner non
madame aurait coûté la vie en fait même
ribeiro et loué l'appartement en cash ce
week-end d'abord elle est plus là et
puis les petits de vous dire qui a eu
des suites pour tout le truc et donc on
a demandé aux gens de partir mais les
gens avaient payé donc du coup on
n'allait pas habiter tous ensemble j'ai
pas mes cours berges à peine avocat mais
non pas ce soir vous allez à l'hôtel et
vous pourrez retourner contre la
concierge mais eux ont payé dans qu ils
sont chez eux jusqu'à ce soir à cannes
la petite croix êtes vous êtes derrière
pouf on a un petit appartement la haie
basse et ou parce que il est arrivé la
même chose à mes narines
ouais elle est rentrée chez elle le soir
elles valent a fait une meuf dans le lit
avec pato et bâle avait loué jusqu'à
10,9 à tulle et galère samedi soir il y
avait donc je boy sur tf1 il y avait les
enfants de la télé sur france 2 qui n'a
pas marché encore les enfants de la télé
voilà c'est deux millions de ces
bactéries devant la télé pour les jeux
qu'on sait que ça les faire beaucoup
plus mais quand on a vu la production de
l'émission les frères c'était la
roumanie sur la tête de ma mère
le plateau mon frère il était grand mais
sans rigoler le plateau il fait à sont
faites sans déconner c'était incroyable
ses enfants de la télé je sais pas si
vous avez regardé je m'attendais à un
truc de ouf parce que c'était
l'anniversaire des enfants de la télé et
c'est vrai que c'était c'était c'était
pas bon on va pas se mentir il y avait
jose boys en face qui a perdu cinq cent
mille téléspectateurs mais qui est quand
même arrivé en tête des audiences mais
c'est toujours comme ça avec les battles
ça perd toujours pas mal alors samedi
soir dans les enfants de la télé
on a eu une chance et qu'ils avaient à m
sila et un médecine à un moment c'est
vrai que je l'embrasserai fort avec
yahoo savez que c'est vraiment mon pote
j'ai encore eu hier au téléphone
c'est une bombe de mecs voilà on l'a
d'or et son spectacle passera d'ailleurs
sur canal+ très bientôt
je vous dirais qu'on est en fait il a il
a dit oui ou non un moment sur la tête
de ma mère quand il dit mon nom parce
qu'il est en direct
on dirait qu'il dit voldemort il est pas
en ra sera mon frère d'isaac laurent ou
kilos pendant cette émission c'est pas
il était blanc mon frère maquiller le
pot sur ma vie attend dix mois il était
blanc
on aurait dit un bain lavabos sont ratés
de mal j'ai envie de me laver les mains
sur lui sur la lune mais regardez le il
était blanc et là il devient encore plus
blanc regarder cette d'arca de la tête
de l'eau en week-end quant à m sila 10
et cyril hanouna dans des pnb et la
frère tu as l'impression que le monde
s'écroule collard bergie ce tu commences
à te paie sa pièce que nous dit j'ai dit
ça c'est le l'action préféré de cyril
hanouna surtout peu mais là c'était
évidemment dans nulle part ailleurs à
l'époque
ryan en 1994 mais en direct et j'ai une
invitée qui a soif mimi vous voulez la
même chose qui tout à l'heure alors on
est allé plus loin on a enquêté on a
réussi à savoir ce que l'on en brique et
penser exactement quand mon frère où
ahmed a parlé nourrir des chocolats
revers juste pour ça te plaît fais ça
qu'est ce que vous dites
elissa c'est le l'action préféré de
cyril hanouna sur mp là c'est évidemment
dans nulle part ailleurs à l'époque
ryan en 1994 mais en direct et j'ai une
invitée qui a soif mimi vous voulez la
même chose qui tout à l'heure et ensuite
oui oui je le vois ça c'est une bande
des auteurs ils sont faits plaisir oui
ça leur ouvrir plus oui d'abord
l'émission était totalement sinistre
ouais c'est vrai dire que honnêtement
moi j'ai regardé mais vraiment pour le
travail et moi challenge on attendait
beaucoup parce que c'est vrai qu'ils ont
pour la télé voilà je suis ça va bien
c'est d'essayer c'était l'anniversaire
s'ils ont tout fait un anniversaire
comme ça c'est très poussiéreux c'est de
la vieille télé franchement c'était un
digg après moi ce qui me gêne sur
ruquier c'est qu'honnêtement je trouve
que on discerne on est trop sympa avec
lui mais je trouve vous le dis à chaque
fois quand même la vérité moi je trouve
que là il ya de la jalousie
il ya du mépris c'est pas bien ce qui
fait c'est une émission qui sans doute
ça je parle du mépris vis-à-vis de vous
c'est de la condescendance david et jean
d'un public populaire
moi j'aime pas ça je sais qu'à chaque
fois vous le défendez vos besoins mais
moi je trouve que c'est trop parce que
c'est comme c'est systématique
ces deux sa part une volonté je trouve
que vous descend gratuitement film
supporte plus sain et sauf que quand
vous qui fait les grosses têtes il
même populaire il faut arrêter monde et
oui les populaires ça reste quand même
une émission populaire les grosses têtes
à la télé ça fait rien on va comme ça
c'est sûr que j'aurais eu l'air vieux
oui
en revanche là où laurent baffie a
raison c'est qu'effectivement vous êtes
très clivant donc soit on vous adore son
vous déteste mais le problème c'est
quand on fait une émission sur la télé
on parle de la télé on se bouge pas le
nez vous faites partie du paf vous êtes
vous vous êtes sur le câble depuis dix
ans jean qu'on fait pas comme si ça
n'existait pas je vous dis la vérité je
me demande si je pense c'était même pas
peut-être méchant je pense que c'est
même pas de quoi parler way à mes
horizons dix enfants ont déjà commencé à
parler en direct par ailleurs moi pardon
oui quoi par ailleurs quand moi il m'a
invité pour la promotion de mon lit bien
sûr évidemment on a parlé de tpm paix on
a parlé aussi et on a montré plein
d'expressions des fils avait même
patrouille par l'équipe je pense qu'il
n'a pas compris de quoi parlait alors
ensuite plus tard dans la soirée on sait
aussi regarder on n'est pas couché et
cette fois ce sont les chroniqueurs de
laurent ruquier qui avait un truc contre
moi les mecs ils voulaient absolument de
fâcheux père jean chalon sont regardés
vous aviez la possibilité semble-t-il de
d'aller chez nous là comme chroniqueur
puis ça s'est pas fait il avait fait une
sortie a pas très longtemps sur cyril
hanouna en disant que vous lui en voulez
y est finalement enfin si j'y suis je
suis je vous avais on voulait bernard
ans et il vous a répondu pierre
joncheray lançant s'enflamment vite les
gens le connaissent depuis deux jours il
a acheté deux guéri dans une théière il
dit je suis l'homme à abattre frais
qu'ils se calment alors ça sans moi j'en
veux pas du tout attiré la lnah si ça
c'est pas fait c'est que france 2 a
contacté y cyril en disant qu'il
préférait que j'étais une personne du
service public qui voulait que je reste
à france télévisions alors je vais vous
dire un truc parce que pierre jean
salençon je l'adoré c'est un ami et il
vient chaque fois dans l'émission c'est
un amour de mecs et oppose vanille par
contre lui lâche plus qu'un ami chaque
fois que je le vois qui me passe la
pommade pendant deux heures et à chaque
fois que je lis et papiers il me défonce
donc je lui dirai oui mais la prochaine
fois de choses en face elle à chaque
fois qu'il fait des papiers dont il
ajouté cris chez plus dans quel journal
et à chaque fois ils m'ont met plein la
gueule et je vois maintenant
l'impression d'avoir vu toutankhamon
alors c'est pas parce qu'on fait là même
d'aider brigitte mâcon et d'emmanuel
mâcon que je vais pas là mais c'est un
article qui était fou mais non c'est moi
qui l'ait dit désolé mais ça vient
à son article mais non mais bêtise non
merci
oui mais là c'était pas son âme avait
pas son article qu'il citait lothering
il renommer vous confondez pas avec
patrick besson parce que luc besson peu
de vie je voudrais bien et c'est dans un
astre le grand bleu il parlait de toi
parler de the voice the voice les
battles qui ont perdu 500 1000 et
parlant mais vous critiquez un peu ric
et il a carrément repris les gros scène
de main de maître je suis en fait partie
cherry donc forcément mais tactique
était l'ancienne nation et je trouve
bruyant nancy n'a jamais dit qu'il était
pas bon dans les airs à radio n'a judy
qui l'époque nuit passages de gameplay
que j'en ai rien à [ __ ] ici je pense
aussi qu'on n'entend n'a pas rien à
[ __ ] je connais je vous dis moi je
pense qu'il était même pot qu'on s'était
pas vraiment méchant après j'aurai une
info sur on n'est pas couché je peux
vous le dire aujourd'hui on n'est pas
couché s'arrête eux ça sera la dernière
saison dont 1,6 c'est sûr et certain
j'y reviendrai c'est lui qui aligne à
des non non je voulais dire un instant
on n'est pas couché va s'arrêter à la
fin de la saison je vous dis c'est sûr
voilà d'un commun accord nous france
télévisions et laurent ruquier ça y est
voilà donc on n'est pas couché voilà
c'est terminé de laurent ruquier reste
sur france télé je vous dis là d'autres
projets avec eux notamment les enfants
de la télé qui vont continuer à priori
voilà et peut-être d'autres projets en
tout cas on n'est pas couché c'est
terminé voilà eric naulleau ça donc fait
un petit pincement au coeur
bah oui je dois beaucoup à cette
émission donc voilà je suis je suis
resté attaché puis de toute façon en
dehors de mon cas personnel c'est
une émission mythique et durs de la
remplacer je voulais le petit facho lot
et voilà j'ai toujours une émission avec
lui tu sais très bien sûr c'est ça qui
est bien
série vous pensez que la case des
sinistrés où ils voient ils vont trouver
quelque chose ça va être très dur de
passer après parce que c'était quasi
mythique maintenant mine de rien c'est
vrai que les audiences ont énormément
baissé aujourd'hui fait entre 700 mille
et mille cent mille téléspectateurs
laurent ruquier dont il ya quand même de
la place après voilà c'est compliqué
mais c'est vrai que je pense qu'il
faudrait près 6 à des formats différents
moi ils m'ont déjà approché ouais je
peux vous dire qu'ils travaillent sur
des nouveaux formats
ils ont quoi en tête en tête de la merde
comme noble jeu complètement différent
en tout cas c'est sûr et certain c'est
terminé on gagne très très dur c'est
quand tu es encore à l'antenne que tu
apprends effectivement que sont déjà en
train de de castet donné d'accord était
décision vécue à priori c'est bien que
serrée non mais il voulait pas continuer
tout fou et oui vous avez pas continuer
ça c'est ce que ça c'est comme quand ta
meuf tous qui te tue 10 m en fait je
tiens comme l'album duck et quand eric
dit c'est une émission mythique je suis
désolé si c'était une émission mythique
après aujourd'hui non mais on ne la
regarde plus d'ailleurs les audiences
baissent il ya plus de 800 milles oui
mais il ya plus de chroniqueur attitré
on le disait récemment c'est plus
précepteur en matière de livres les gens
ne veulent plus y aller donc qui a
toutes les raisons quelque chose à sa
règle a donc je possédais voilà bien la
re d'idées dans la rue 1
la folle a fait beaucoup de mal la folle
angot a bien coulé alors je vous le dis
mais en tout cas ça a été un énorme
succès ça on peut pas le nier c'est un
succès pendant de nombreuses années je
souhaite à beaucoup d'émissions d'avoir
autant de succès pendant autant de temps
les chéris the voice les battles
doivent-elles s'arrêter parce que c'est
vrai que moi voilages achats j'adore the
voice cette année mais j'ai l'impression
depuis le sol ça me rend fou sont des
clones et chaque semaine il perdre des
téléspectateurs 3.9 millions cette
semaine et j'ai eu à chaque fois je me
dis hier que moi qui faisais au vox en
fait je comprends pas alors pourtant il
ya eu des bons moments d'émotion dans
l'émission on a vu notamment marc
lavoine
pleurer pour vous devez choisir entre
pierre et louise et c'était très dur ça
m'a rappelé les larmes de djibril dans
top chef quand il a raté son double
c'est une rivière à traverser heat a
pris dans ses bras et a déposé de
l'autre côté de la rive pour tout te
dire vas-y j'aurais vraiment aimé vous
gardez trouvé des os c'est difficile
parce que
vous vous plaisez
et perdre
j'ai gardé le blues
[Applaudissements]
et s'il arrêtait les battles oui je
rallume moi j'adore j'adore cette
émission mais là effectivement j'ai
regardé j'ai regardé samedi soir avec
les enfants et en fait on est entre
l'orgasme et le cataclysme lacrymal
c'est à dire que ça devient juste
ridicule c'est sûr ils regardent cc soit
il la regarde on n'en peut plus et
surtout il faut qu'ils arrêtent de
mentir aux candidats une à chaque fois y
est c'est extraordinaire ce que tu fais
tu vas faire une grande carrière
j'attends ton album quand en fait
j'étais au concert là mais en fait
arrêter de prendre les gens pour des
cons parce qu'en fait on prend
téléspectateurs pour des cons et moi je
trouve que c'est toute la limite
aujourd'hui de ce programme là en fait
vous n'aimez pas sien je suis venu et
passagers
on en oublie qu'il est justement
peut-être vrai parce que c'est pas
souvent les gagnants qui sont le plus
connu et il fonde la plus belle carrière
donc ouais après sa sortie du spectacle
c'est normal qu'on leur dise des choses
et pourquoi pas après pour ce qui s'agit
des larmes de marc lavoine
on sait qui fait pas semblant de pleurer
et que c'est des vraies émotions qu'il
ressent moi mais je comprends pas cette
histoire de battles on sait à chaque
fois que ça fait baisser les audiences
pourquoi on cherche pas un autre truc
est d'accord une autre est mieux c'est
que ça marche pas pourquoi on continue
pourquoi on cautionner ça jean-michel
intérêt de cette émission c'est de
découvrir des nouveaux talents de
découvrir le l'on se retourne on voit
les gens qui chantent comme ça une fois
que vous avez chanté une fois on a rien
à [ __ ]
on sent du compte ça banalise et
totalement la notion de talent de
chanteur on se rend compte que eu pour
effet l'émission montre ça tous les mois
ils voient tous les mois des très belles
des gens qui chantent très bien ça à
banaliser et quand tu dis que marc
labrèche suis désolé il se baisse et la
cena
il pleurait très peu avant il avait les
yeux revolver un voulait donc ne dis pas
de bêtises et eibar cloud plus je sors
de la mer c'est pourquoi vous êtes
jaloux parce qu'il est beau ça vous
énerver les sens exact avec un zizi
voilà ordinaire que la carrière qu'il a
marc lavoine et 30 ans de carrière il
remplit des salles mais team sert il a
rien à prouver à personne en plus des
salaires en paix défini festif non mais
il fait des films il fait tout maryse
avoine il parle peu mais qui connaît pas
c'est génial
et si génial c'est magnifique j'adore
alors on rappelle que c'est en
partenariat avec rtl isabelle type assis
non666 a écrit en bas de l'écran et
suburbain ce n'est pas moi j'adore ça je
m'en fiche moi non madame tout ce qui me
gêne c'est que guerrière d'énergie c'est
à dire que d'un seul coup on en perd la
moitié est alors pour le coup aux
tensions à perdre qu'à chaque fois
gratter des batailles l'arrestation de
moi je pense que c'est trop j'ai passé
trop brutal pour le coup trop radicale
sauf qu elle vraiment d'états d'âme ont
été comparés aux parents et leurs jetons
qu'à une règle blizzard va arriver un
trio par exemple un trio s'est monté mon
préféré moi c'était le plus harmonieux
de toute la soirée et la lara fabian le
droit d'en récupérer un tu dis mais
c'est quoi cette règle étoiles à deux
endroits
mais pourquoi non on n'a pas deux ans on
est trop technique lâché décrocher non
mais il faut arrêter de faire croire aux
gens qu'ils vont faire tous une carrière
mais c'est supportable et ridules il ya
un énorme problème c'est que le jury sur
joue en permanence
mais si vous poussez pas pu compenser le
vide pour compenser le vide du casting
les la vida sont si mauvais euro par le
jury à la mairie
ça oui les îles qui est déjà à défaut
les oignons se casse la gueule alors et
danse garée juste les audiences de télé
de la télé baisse en général et aux
vosges et bas souffrent aussi
mine de rien comme tout le monde
vendredi sur tf1 il y avait des enfants
rien en parlera dans un instant juste
une dalle sondage sur koh lanta mais il
ya bien sûr
va-t-il arrêter les bateaux louis à 72h
est d'accord alors vendredi donc y avait
des [ __ ] alors c'est un carton
contre l'herpès génital j'aimerais bien
voir le avoir les fans de koh lanta
était dégoûté de devoir attendre une
semaine pour retrouver un nouvel épisode
est justement à propos de koh lanta on a
appris quelque chose qui a choqué pas
mal de monde c'est inès l'aventurière
qui avait fait le buzz pour son fameux
maillot de bain qui a décidé de répondre
à plusieurs questions sur son instinct
et il ya une révélation qui a fait du
bruit
regardez si on sait que koh lanta est le
programme parfait pour tester ses
limites est allé puiser au fond de soi
les ressources insoupçonnées d'un héros
le programme d' aventure de tf1 pourrait
également être 2 place to be pour pécho
et c'est inès la candidate qui avait
fait sensation en ce début de saison
avec son maillot de bain sexy qui a
révélé quelques coulisses du jeu si elle
confirme qu'il n'y a pas de toilettes
sur l'île pas non plus de rasoir les
candidats les plus téméraires ont tout
de même de quoi s'amuser puisque dans la
boîte à pharmacie mise à disposition des
candidats on peut tout de même trouver
des préservatifs
ça ne m'a absolument pas traversé
l'esprit mais il y en a en effet dans la
boîte à pharmacie des préservatifs
occasions et qu'on se le dise après
trois semaines d'aventuré sans douche
sans savon sans brosse à dents son
rasoir sans parfum et sans manger
celui qui décide quand même de faire
l'amour devrait au moins gagné un totem
d'immunité
en tous les cas pour la production mieux
vaut prendre toutes les précautions même
s'il ya de grandes chances que ces
préservatifs la rentrer à paris encore
emballés
[Musique]
alors franchement moi soutiennent
polémique
ouais je sais très bien qu'il est
présent oui mais c'est choquant
guillemets aleri on lorsqu'on leur
tomberait dessus si y'avait pas
justement al'inverse parce qu'on
rappelle que basse et non pas aller les
chercher dans le sable indispensable
mais donc avec un poulpe pas le gars qui
partage avec ng choucha poule a
longtemps raconté qu'il n'est absolument
pas de libido soeurs williams étant je
vais bien même au contraire très bien
vous mettez jean-michel mer sur l'île
sage patrons qu'ils passent comme un
linge en est à se bouffer le bigorneau
en forêt de haye bien sûr on ils sont
pas tous mariés il peut y avoir des
célébrations après un rasoir s'est pas
vital en chantant c'est pas vital un
préservatif salaire exact avant tout
regarder la belle isabelle sur pékin
express j'avais des préservatifs qui
avait déposé un petit peu pékin express
absolument vous allez mais quand vous
avez blanche vous jure vous n'avez pas
été toute la journée vous pensé à tout
sauf à la baguette du monde ayant peu de
rose
[Applaudissements]
on en compte avec la neige suis pas sûr
qu'il se serait donné qu'il y a pas
besoin de la barre si c'est à koh lanta
c'est un c'est un plan c c'est pas là
pas du tout mais cette folle ou quoi
mais tu sais que cette histoire là voilà
ma santé express arrêté fin mai au sénat
pourquoi allez on passe à autre chose
d'avoir va pas mettre une méduse au bout
de route du si simon n'a pas dit ça mais
ça y est lente et inégale de koh lanta
comme une star du x à serris bas en tout
cas je vois pas très bien passée mais
son plus gros savait pas été sur un
tracé dans le premier numéro de koh
lanta saison souvient qu'elle avait
choisi une culotte qui avait fait
beaucoup parler rien les jeunes
poursuivent
inès va débuter son ascension cette
année sur les côtés pour pouvoir chacun
prendra part à l'est la 4e cordes
applique ces
inès doit tricoter son échelle
il faut que la corde soit bien tendu
[Applaudissements]
voilà année elle arrive à l'épreuve des
poteaux elle s'assoit les banquiers
n'ont alors je veux dire il ne fait pas
partie de l'émission est invité voilà je
le dis je le redis aux téléspectateurs